hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled extracellular vesicles
in regenerative medicine this webinar is
part of the
cell biology virtual event and i'm susie
valdez of libraries and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational
and offers free continuing education
credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab on the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits i now present today's
speaker
dr benedetta lottie
who's a lottie apologize associate
professor of nephrology in the
department of molecular biotechnology
and health
science university of torino and the
president of the italian society of
extracellular vesicles
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr visolati thank you for coming you may
now begin your presentation
welcome
hello everyone thank you susie for
the nice introduction uh jesus was
saying
i am working at the university of torino
in italy
and that's where i am connected from
so today's presentation
we mainly focus as we said on
regenerative medicine
and that's briefly the agenda
i will first go through
a presentation on what extracellular
vesicles
are showing you how
they are important for long-distance
communication
i know you had a previous presentation
on assassination this morning but for
those who connect just now
for those connecting offline i will just
spend
a small time on that and then i will
switch on the focus of this presentation
stem cell mainly stamps cells
for regeneration and as i am a
nephrologist
i will focus on the kidney as
a typical organ but
what i'm saying for the kidney is also
true for many other
organs and then focus on
biodistribution of vision vivo
a focus on the cargo of these and on the
mechanism involved
and finally i will spend some time on
the possible clinical application of
these some examples of clinical trials
which are the limits and which are the
promises
okay so we all know that um
tissue damage happens and our
organs are in many instances able
to put in place some repair
so we have necrosis of the tissues we
have lots of capillaries
infiltration of inflammatory cells
possible modulation of pericytes
that transform into frequency
fibromyalgia
so what happens this process
of repair not always
ends in adaptive repair meaning
we get the organ
repair the end function of the organ
but in some instances we
face a more adaptive repair
so why does it happen
maladaptive repair may happen due to
an excessive damage on the tissue
or loss of the cells that could be
um involved in uh in repairing could be
in charge or repairing the tissues such
as stem cells
or progenitor cells we may lose the
vascularization
of the organs or have a vessel
refraction
cell senescence in many instances
compromises the ability of the organ
to occur and it's very important that
epigenetic pro-fibrotic changes may
happen
in those organs
so fibrosis is
considered a disease of cell
reprogramming
that's one example the pericype that we
program into myofibroblasts
so fibrosis is really
the example of maladaptive repair
the final ending of the organ function
and also in patients
it's really important that to underline
that
epigenetic modifications in profit
biotics
genes are associated with fibrosis
development
so why i am am i focusing on that
that's very relevant for um
understanding the rationale of using
extracellular vesicles and why
reprogramming
of a whole tissue is really readable
so um
it must be well understood that
one single
target it's not enough to
obtain uh the restoration of the older
function
we might target tgf for fibrosis we
might target
other genes but that's not enough
clearly to get rid of those
epigenetic changes we really need a
reprogramming of the whole
tissue
and so that's why we are
just focusing on extracellular vesicles
because extracellular vesicles
and we i will give you the proof of that
are tiny vesicles
that have a very specific
and peculiar function in modulating
target organ and
mediating exchange of their cargo
namely extracellular rnas
to reprogram the target tissue
and in that obviously stem cell derived
extracellular vesicles
have a permanent role
okay so um what are these extracellular
vesicles
that's the definition that i like very
much um
we need to consider that there are vesic
very small vesicles
in the range of nano nanometers
nano-sized vesicles
they are produced by the cell secretory
machinery
and they are released in the biological
fluid
to have an effect on multiple
long-distance intercellular
communication
so these electron microscope images
that show you the main pathways of
production
of extracellular vesicles so
extracellular vesicles is a very general
term that comprises different types of
vesicles
released by cells so we mainly
divide them in small and large vesicles
obviously depending on the size but also
in part related to the mechanism of
origin so
vesicles might be released in
in by cells by fusion
of multivesicular bodies when these
vesicles
are present on the surface of the cell
so typically those vesicles present in
the multivesticular bodies
are small and they are called exosomes
vesicles can also be released by budding
on the side
surface typically those vesicles
are larger but that's not always true
and they are mainly called micro
vesicles
but as a general term we prefer to call
them small
and large vesicles
we have as i was saying information
inside the vesicles proteins
extracellular rna
lipids and
[Music]
all this multitude of factors
are actively and selectively
compartmentalized within the vesicles
so they resemble the cell of origin
but they are not just the same content
of a normal cytoplasmic
content of a cell and in this really
fundamental paper it was shown that if
we analyze the microrna
present in in vesicles and in cell
they are not absolutely the same they
really
um separate and we have
small and large testosterone vesicles
that even
share different types of
content
and another important feature of these
vesicles
is the surface
so the eddy surface presents
many receptors many molecules that are
necessary
for the targeting of um
cells of long distance communication
so vesicles can be internalized within
vesicles in different ways
and the sighted receptor dependent
um undecided can be fused with the
membrane
can be undecided to clarity independent
endocytosis and when they release the
content
they might have their biological effect
so a large number of studies show
evidence that rna
presenting vesicles can be translated
and can be active
that's just an example using um bicycles
with containing hermes and rna in a
reporter mouse in which
gfp could be
um synthetized
after um getting the messenger and avs
and it's clear that after intracellular
interventricular injection we have
neurons
that are positive for the gfp
and again also many uh papers
demonstrated the transfer
of specific micrornas to target cells
these adjusting vitro experiments should
increase
in the micrornas
in cells after targeting with
extracellular vesicles containing those
and on the right you can also see
fluorescently labeled
micrornas that entered into south and
the target
by western blood was shown to be de
based and obviously after 48 hours
the target was expressed by the cells
so all this has a relevance has a
relevance in pathology
as it was shown that it is mainly
involved in disease propagation
uh for instance ev's from
mice with hypertension that were
administered through healthy mice could
transfer
the same hypertensive feature and that's
a very
from the group of eliot and for
somewhere
but going to regenerative medicine
um the attention
ago at the beginning at least two of
these
from progenitor cells as they really
appear a unique tool
in the control of tissue organ
regeneration
so the beginning was that it is may
recapitulate
the effect of stem cell entirely tissues
and they were doing that displaying
long long term tissue reprogramming
and i invite you to go through these two
seminal papers that were the first
to show the effect of themselves
their ideas
and messengers themselves
are the best example of um
sensors for generative medicine i mean
they are the mostly used in clinical
trials
and obviously they have been the first
as a possible
use of extracellular vesicles
in that application so from camera
stars derived from different origins
bone marrow was mainly the first and
then adipose tissue
has a great interest synovium
umbilical cord and many others and they
have a combined
activity on immune regulation and
possible
multi-lineage differentiation
so these cells release actively release
esoteric that
might be used uh for regenerative
medicine
so these are some electron microscopy
studies showing
the release vesicles from those cells
and you can very easily see that
uh these vesicles on the right release
are very different in size there are
some smaller ones
some larger one and also the mechanism
is very different
production some are come from the body
as we can see in the right
panel some in the left panel
we can see the arrows showing a
multivesticular body that
fuses them with the surface so
um we must take in consideration
that extracellular vesicles released
from a cell
from a cell source in general
are anterior genius population
and we need to characterize them and
possibly to understand the possible
function population of these and their
nature
and their characteristics with the idea
of
going on with possible theoretical
applications
of these so that's another
tool that is very useful in the
super resolution microscopy
obviously working with such small
degrees
it's very important that the technology
provides
tool to analyze to understand that and
that's
happening more and more um you know with
with
the progression of knowledge
so we can see here
um uh
500 nanometers up to the one
on on the right is a typical uh 15
58 nanometer extracellular
and there are a lot of criteria that
come by the international society
of estacional vesicles
with the idea of trying to define
those those vesicles
the expression of markers which are
characteristically sacral vesicles we
see here cd63 cd9 cd81 and alex
also we have the nano view which
is a new instrument um that
allows us to and to analyze
uh the uh markers is
the maxplex which is
a beast-based cytoplametric assay
that allows the comparison of multifocus
and so it's very important to show that
those vesicles press
typical exosomal markers and then they
also express
markers of the telogens such as
mesenchymal stomach
markers that we can see here such as
cd29 cd 146 cb105
and outside it's another instrument that
allows us
to count the number of particles
in in a supernatant
and to analyze the mean size
if we also analyze the content of
micrornas of those vesicles
that have been performed by several
groups this was one of the first
analysis and that showed quite clearly
that
the processes which modulated by those
micrornas involved the main pathways
of organ development metabolic processes
pronunciation
okay so that's irrational for the
application of
vesicles in models of damage
and i'd like to show you those graphs
which come from a very first
um paper from our group
in which a mouse was subjected to acute
kidney injury
and at day one cells
mesenchymal stress and particles
obtained by the same dose of cells
so that those equivalent were injected
and um it's very clear
analyzing the function of the kidney
which is here the creatinine
and the boon that a very rapid
gain of function was obtained both
with vesicles and with cells
and if we also check logical appears
we can see that in mice with aki
um there's a a
great um necrosis
all those pinky elements
are cast that represents necrotic
tubules
with accumulation of proteins and that's
not happening
in administrative with cells with
medical mastermind cells
or with vesicles but if
those vesicles were treated with their
name that's what i would mention but
first
experiment that the effect of the
vesicles was lost
so we also tried to understand where
those cycles were going
after in individual injection
and we can see that in the heart mice
the vesicles were mainly going into
clean into the liver but in the aki
mouth the kidneys were
a target organ and you can see
also in in the lower panels uh
the different kidneys that were
recovered
24 hours after a cellular vesicle
injection
that are all full of extracellular
vesicles
that's the red color
so that tells us that
after organ damage the vesicles
might accumulate nobles and that could
be possibly due to increasing
[Music]
to damage to the tissue and loss
of the barriers that normally
compromise this limit
but we can also speculate that some
specific
mechanism of targeting might be
occurring
and um here we can also
appreciate how fast is the accumulation
of the vesicles in the organ after
injection
so we see that after 50 minutes we don't
have much accumulation but after five
hours
the organs are already getting a very
high concentrations
the liver and the spleen
are always targeted by vesicles
so those are the mainly organs in which
the vesicles
are cleaved both in a normal healthy
mouth
and in the aki
so we must take that into consideration
and
we might also imagine some uh
modification of the bicycles that might
prevent
the accumulation of of them
into those organs
and here that's the confirmation just by
a monofluorescence of the presence of
the vesicles
in that so we can see here in the
vessels after
five minutes in the upper panel you have
vesicles
and after 15 minutes the vesicles are
already present
tubular structures that appear right
here
in the right panel
so that's a more recent
work uh showing again a comparison
between the cells and the vesicle which
i think is
very interesting again the model is in
peaks
um which received the diet and then
a stenosis of adrenal artery um
to get in four weeks um a profound
damaged kidneys so we have fibrosis
to the kidney and we can see that both
vesicles
and the cells expect a very therapeutic
effect
on limiting the fibrosis
of the kidney but what's very
interesting
in these pre progress
could discriminate some peculiar effects
on the vesicles
uh towards those of the cells
the cells could preferentially
ameliorate vascularization
as we see in the upper panel the number
of vessels
with the mesenchymal thermal cells and
at variance the vesicles
show the preferential effect on tissue
pressure production
and the limitation of apoptosis which is
shown in
in the lower panel on the right
another example of a long
term administration of extracellular
vesicles
comes from this paper
in which a diabetic mouse
was treated in a curative model
after the diabetic onset
the the study waited 28 days before
administration of extracellular vesicles
once a week for four weeks
and again we can see a very nice effect
of the vessel of coming from the
mesenchyma so myself i apologize
this light has some changes
so those were examples if you go to the
literature
you will find a large number of studies
showing the effect of these in acute
kidney injury
and chronic kidney disease
those concepts are solid disease
might have a regenerative effect
although there is not a consensus
in this type of injection different
administration
were performed different numbers
even the v are not counted in the same
way
some studies count them in numbers some
others
in microgram some others
in cell equivalence and that's still a
very
big limitation in the field to compare
different
styles
so going a bit more in into details
in what's happening in the organs
treated with vesicles
if we compare a by
rna set the
presence of the heat map of the
genes and the control in the disease
situation
and in disease situation plastical we
may
find that many genes
were reverted to the normal conditions
and in the case of the diabetic kidneys
those
genes were mainly related to the
fibrosis and it's very interesting to
um to note that a very similar effect
was also observed in liver
undergoing fibrosis in a nash model
so that doesn't seem to be typical for
the kidney but rather a general
mechanism
of reprogramming as i was telling you
so again a lot many
prophy body genes were modulated and
reverted after free
right exocellular vesicles
so can we decide which
of the eterogenes natural he is
responsible for their biological
effect that's not easy and
several approaches can be taken one for
possible approach
was to um
was to divide the vesicles into small
and large
by um subsequential
ultracentrifugation so we can see here
10 kbs which are the first going down
which are the large
eb's and one and
kevs that are the ones that
remain in the palace after 100k
g centrifugation
so the comparison
showed that indeed the 100k
was the main responsible for the
winner so the repair of the
necrosis and of the castes
was gained mainly using the 100k
fraction rather than the pancake
fraction
and that was very similar to what
obtained with the total is
we understand which other factors
involved in that regeneration if we
compare the two populations
that has been performed in that
[Music]
and a number of micrornas that
you can go and check were identified
that were mainly involved in
proliferative anti-population
so what's what's the role of those
micrornas are
really they domain
responsible for the biological release
so some study really suggests that
so micrornas have been
cleaved in mesenchymal consulting
regenerating joshua
knockout cells and then getting the bees
from the ocean of calcium
you might well know that russia is
involved in
uh the maturation of
micrornas and then obviously
the extracellular vesicles we contain
the incarnates so going directly to the
results
we can see that the drop shall knock out
these
were not able to revert necrosis
fast and renal function
and in the same way those evs were not
able to reprogram
to get that
mechanism that we were describing of
reprogramming the tissue
toward a normal aspect
so that's an analysis of the dna sec
of the tissue showing that the renal
transcriptome
of the mice treated with
these without micrornas
was very similar to that
of of damage aka
mice and variants the tissue
of mice treated with contrary bees
was
comparable was
getting almost a similar translation
of that of healthy mass
so is this just what
we can speculate um
micrornas are total of the
effect of a division now there are for
sure also
very important other factors among which
we recently studied a protein
factor which can be carried by
some vesicles uh present in the urine
so i don't want to make a very long
story about that
but just to give you this example we
obtain vesicles from
urine of normal subjects and
we found out that those vesicles had an
effect that was very similar
to that of mesenchymal stem cellular
disease
in terms of restoring urinal function
in an acute model of damage
and um again that's they stimulated
tubular cell proliferation they limited
apoptosis so what was the mechanism
um it was very interesting for us to
find out that
um extracellular vesicles from urine and
variants of those from mesenchymal
stomach cells
contain clover which is
a factor that is typically released by
the kidney
and it's very important as an anti-aging
and regenerative factor
so that's just the proof that
the kidney is the principal organ
that releases slow tone and mice without
nephronic proto might knock out um
[Music]
for clothes specifically in the kidney
had almost no clothes or released any
circulation
so clothes is very interesting as i was
telling you
as it's one of the main factors in our
body
which controls the aging mice without
clothes are really appreciated
and um they present the typical features
of aging like endothelial dysfunction
calcification
atherosclerosis hypertrophy of the
cardiovascular system
and pluto is released in the circulation
as a small cleaved form
and of interest the vesicle from the
urine
carried this soluble small form
of clutter
that's another proof that clothing is
present on the vesicles
going on to analyze the vesicles that
carry the stroke not all the vesicles in
the urine
here clutter but rather a large flash
version
of them and um
that's a cool expression of clothes and
a
necessarily vesicle marker analyzed by
a super resolution microscopy
so when we administer
urinary vesicles we found that that plot
which was lost after
the damage was regained in the kidney
fitted with urinary vesicles
the same was obtained at
um
messenger rna level and at protein
levels so
possibly party is due to induction of
clutter partly
could be also due to transfer but what's
true
is that urinary cellular vesicles and
variants of medications themselves
vesicles had this peculiar effect
and vesicle for my step
were knocked out for pluto lacked the
regenerative effect
showing that kloto was indispensable
in the renal protective effect of those
vesicles
so that's just an example of a protein
factor that could be carried by these
and may exert
a very important therapeutic effect
and obviously these factors can be used
for engineering
inactive vesicles so we engineered
fibroblast tvs
with um soluble clutter and
again we got it these that were
active as a therapeutic effect
so again ev's curving clutter
could protect the
kidneys after damage at variance of the
fibroblast tvs
without clutter
okay so i cannot go much in the details
but
um i would like to uh to save the last
um seven eight minutes
um for the final discussion
on uh which is the therapeutic potential
of those obese so we
we proved mainly preclinical settings
that
it is um have really
a potential interest
they have the possibility to target
multiple organs
and to reprogram tissue acting with the
synergy of factors
possibly many factors in the content in
the cargo of evs
are doing the job simultaneously and
it's very important that
they may program the tissue they may
target at the same time
different levels different
mechanisms they seem to be
avoiding some typical stem cell
limitation they are
um biocompatible they should not have
tumorogenic
and multidifferentiative effect
and they as the stem cells
seem to be non-immunogenic
and we had a first feasibility study in
which
extracellular vesicles from mesenchymal
cells
have been administered to one patient in
a compassionate
use the patient had a very
important graft versus sauce which was
refractory
to all therapies and was treated
with mesenchymal stomach exosomes
showing a great improvement of many of
the symptoms
of the um graft versus disease
so that's the kind of diarrhea so
um that's um
the epithelial damage uh of the
intestine
uh that's um loss of some
typical edimatotic lesions that's
loss of uh some
other typical
[Music]
necrotic lesions of the gut vessel sauce
and uh it's not of
um you know um
great
difference the fact that um many
clinical trials
are now um starting using ebs
for organ regeneration so the number the
list if you go
on on a clinical trial stop glass
is very long here are the
main that i found just yesterday
some of them are recruiting few are
completed
and um obviously
if we go on the condition we might say
that
[Music]
lung diseases and covet 19 related
diseases are among the least
that's not um i mean that's
that's quite obvious in this period
uh but we have already results from the
first
clinical uh trial um it is
two tree that was um
studying the effect of umbilical cords
in chemistry and surgery disease
in in patients with chronic human
disease
related to the diabetic condition
so this trial was ended
some time ago was performed in egypt
and um we had
as you can see from the graph um
quite a stabilization if not saying an
amelioration of the glomerular
filtration rate which is the kidney
function
in the patient's with a vesicle
in comparison with patients in the
control group
which had a decline in the function
also the results of the trials of the
first trial
using exosome from bone marrow
mesenchyma stem cells
are now published showing safety the
treatment
[Music]
and again you can go and check out
the paper what i think is very important
uh in this moment to underline
is that there are many
open questions and many points that
even trials
that are done in this extremely
specific and and and peculiar period
must follow and um
a letter was also sent to the others or
the people you can
you can go and read that so the
international society for assassination
and that
for cell engine therapy underlined the
necessity
of following several criteria
of stringent identity of what
is produced and
given to the patient potency parameters
obviously we still need to address
many potential side effects
we need very strong criteria
for manufacturing in these
and that must be done in gmp
with definition of safety and clinical
pharmacologic
pharmacology and we really still need to
acquire a lot of experience
and knowledge on that on the
[Music]
conditions for optimal storage for
optimum optimal dosing and for
the administration of cellular vesicles
also it's important to
make some consideration on the on the
surface of bicycles we want to
administer
having potency tests um we need to
consider that
these from different
um subjects might have
a strong variability so aging and young
uh mesenchymal stromal cells
may produce effective or non-effective
it is
has been shown in in several
clinical data and also
it is from disease patients such as
obese patients might have
strong differences in respect to
invest from cells obtaining from normal
patients
so there's still a long
way to go
[Music]
i'd like to also show you this very
nice light coming from a web if we talk
in this period you can
you can find
[Music]
you can find uh online this ad
talk series and in one of those there
was also
a presentation by dr fujita of a
possible application
of our torah whose non-stem cell is
but rather in this carrying from primary
cells
so don't forget also the primary cells
could also be really
important as therapeutic tools
so i just want to end um underlined
the need of
identity potency definitions
those and administration so we still
need to provide many
data before we can really go into the
clinic with safe
products so thank you all for your
attention
and thank you to all the people who
contributed to generate
this data
thank you dr abushawati for that
informative presentation and we will now
begin the q a portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we have several questions already coming
in dr bishov latti
why does maladaptive response
occur
so i think i mean in my presentation i
just pointed out
the main possible um
reasons for that
aging and exhaustion of
mechanism cells that could be involved
in repair it's one possibility
so we lose with aging
stem cells that's well known also the
extent
of the damage if we are facing an
incredible
uh very um extense
damage we may not be able to repair it
obviously but also continuous mechanism
of damage
like chronic diseases uh mainly may lead
to
important reductive mechanism
and dr bisolati why are organs
such as the kidney and liver more
refractory
to stem cell based regenerative
regeneration regenerative techniques
well um i think
i mean stencil based regenerative
techniques uh can be applied
to those organs um i mean
in this right moment we haven't really
found
an effective therapy i have to admit
that we don't have
therapies that work i would say
for all really all the orders the
the um
the possible um you know strategies that
have been approved by fda for instance
that
that have been really proven to be
effective are really
really few so many organs
are refractory and it's well known that
stem cells when they are administered
they don't really go and transform into
the cells
of the organ so they do not regenerate
and
they just produce factors such as
extracellular vesicles secretor
manufacturers that help your organ if
it's possible to repair
thank you doctor lady and thank you to
our audience members for these great
questions
we have time for two more questions what
is ev's
regenerative success for acute
um renal failure and for chronic
renal failure
so um as i was saying we had
um many uh data
from pre-clinical um experiments
and they showed you know effect
both in acute and in chronic obviously
chronic
a single liver administration
mainly fails to prepare we need
multiple administration
i mean all models have it it's it's
standard criteria but um possibly
for chronic um um
you know diseases chronic kidney disease
we we need
a a continuous um administration of
these but um the success
in pre-clinical uh experiments even you
know in large animals
has been clearly proven and we already
had one child
so that's some hope let's say
thank you so much our final question are
there any environmental
or diet factors that promote the life
of stem cells in a kitten
ah that's that would be nice to know
i don't think we i mean we know and we
can answer to that
uh diet factor it's difficult to say
uh for sure i mean uh
stem cells in the kidney are not even
um well this fat possibly there are some
progenitor cells
but it's quite elusive so um
we know that those cells proliferate so
um
we need to preserve them not make them
proliferate too much to exhaust their
function but
um i don't know if there's
any any factor that has that will be
interesting to study
thank you so much and actually we have
one more question that just came in
do messenger channel cells stem cells
seem to be the most promising for
kidney regeneration and healing and if
not
which do
yeah i mean those were the first studied
and
um yeah the mostly used in clinical
trials so
yeah they appear the most uh promising
but
uh i wouldn't really limit to that uh i
think i mean
we have been studied urinary evs and and
many other
groups have been studied uh these from
renal cells so
it could be possibly could be that a
primary um source
of cells which are or vesicles which
come from cells
that are of the whole kidney um
maintain a signature that helps to
uh to restore to
to have a therapeutic effect on the
organ rather than
simply stem cells
which are very generic like
cells dr basilari thank you again for
your time today
and for your important research thank
you this was great
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us for today and
for their interesting questions
and any questions that we do not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months until
march of 2021.
alert laboratory via email when it's
available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care and stay
healthy
bye everyone